Ranjan now by the independent pension
consultants John Ralph John you know
about more about this scheme than most
people why is it in such a pickle
hello in its in a pickle it's the
largest scheme in the country it's got
the largest deficit it's completely out
of control and it hasn't been properly
managed universities seem to be in
denial about the problem certainly USF
seems to be in denial about the problem
and I'm not sure whether they're
grabbing it by the scruff of the neck
and sorting it out properly so what's
the problem I mean obviously we heard a
lot about pension deficits being
exaggerated by the fact that the
discount rate interest rates are very
very low is it down to that or is it
down to bad investment a certain number
of things lots of companies are closing
their pension schemes it's just too
expensive to have the traditional final
salary pension where you get a certain
amount of pension depending how long you
work for the company people are living
too long and the amount that you can get
on the money that invested has just gone
down and was absolutely no reason to
think that USS should be immune from
that USS has exaggerated the problem its
problems very much of its own making
because it's taken a bet over the last
40 years since it was set up it's taking
a bet on equities for the first 2025
years that paid off for the last few
years it hasn't and my concern is that
USS is in denial about that so what's
the pension regulator done about this
have they should they have stopped the
rot well we don't know I mean the
pension regulator is very important
pension regulators have had a kicking in
over the last few months with working
pension Select Committee on on BHS for
example I think the pension regulator
will be looking at this very carefully
we don't know what the pension regulator
thinks the pension regulator isn't going
to tell us and universities aren't going
to tell us but they certainly will be
taking a very very careful notice
because of the size of this the the
underlying deficit and the potential
problems that that might create so one
of the university is going to have to do
to close the gap I mean this is the key
reason presumably why tuition fees
having to rise is well we don't know
universities would say there isn't that
cause you're linked but if more money
has to go into the pension scheme you
mentioned a seventeen and a half billion
deficit we're talking about University
contributions having to double just to
plug that deficit that's got to come
from somewhere where does it come from
well it's got to come from student fees
student fees don't necessarily you know
go from nine thousand to ten thousand
but this quality of education probably
goes down generational unfairness issue
here in that young lecturers people
coming into the university system now to
teach are now going to have to make more
of a contribution to their pensions or
in some cases even to pay for more
generous pensions for I think that's
right
I think we're going to find that the the
younger lecturers will end up when they
retire with a letter with a smaller
pension than the people who are you know
on the verge of retirement now
nevertheless I think that what USS has
got to do what Universities UK has got
to do which represents all the
universities is bite the bullet they've
got to close the defined benefit final
salary scheme altogether they've got to
move to defined contribution set at a
fairly generous level and then they've
got to use the money that they save to
plug the deficit and I'm not sure
whether there are many more chances for
them to do that they fudged it three
years ago I think if they fudge it now
rather than taking drastic action you
know it's only going to get worse so
very briefly John if they don't do
something fairly shortly then this is
going to tip universities into a bigger
financial crisis I think well I think
all we will be doing is kicking the can
down the road
alright John Ralph we've got to leave it
there I'm afraid thanks for joining me
good see